our i-team has been looking into alleged
voter fraud across our state during
today's news conference by the trump
campaign
they announced a lawsuit against clark
county and introduced a woman who said
she went to vote only to be told she
already had
our own i-team reporter david charn
spoke with her earlier this week david
yeah so kirsten this lawsuit again as
hector just said it's yet to be filed
that again claims ten thousand people
who are either dead or no longer living
here in nevada voted
but the trump campaign and the
republican party didn't show any
evidence of this happening now we did
introduce you
to jill stokey back on monday we brought
you that she's legally blind and needs
assistance to vote but
when she went to vote early she was told
she already voted
now she says she went to go in person
but that her mail-in ballot had been
sent
in and yeah her signature match that's
what they told her
but stokey is adamant that she did not
vote and she believes her ballot was
stolen
clark county's joe gloria did not go as
far
to say that stokey was lying when asked
about this today but said in their mind
she did vote i personally dealt with ms
stoke
she brought her claim to me we reviewed
the ballot and in our opinion it's her
signature
we also gave her an opportunity to
provide a statement
if she wanted to object to that and
provide a challenge to that she refused
to do so
a member of the nevada secretary of
state's office investigation team also
interviewed her
and they had no issue with the
assistance that we tried to give her
i have nothing else to comment on that
next question that reporter saying
did you think she was lying and of
course you heard his answer there now in
today's news conference stokey mentioned
us here at channel 8
saying that i had told her we had
received emails and calls about voter
inconsistencies
i told stokey when i interviewed her and
the i-team has repeatedly reported
voter fraud is extremely rare and our
sources tell us there is no any there is
no widespread coordinated effort of any
kind
of voter fraud lots more on this coming
up next new at five o'clock i'm david
charns 8 news now
thank you david nevada state democratic
party chair william mccurdy releasing a
statement in response to the lawsuit
threat it reads in part quote
today in a shameful display partisan
hacks attack the integrity of nevada's
voting system without evidence
threatening to disenfranchise the voices
of their fellow nevadans in the process
end quote